irán comparte una frontera de 900
kilómetros con afganistán en ese momento
el gobierno iraní tenía absolutamente
malas relaciones con los talibán y ellos
de hecho en su momento
ayudaron en él a pesar de todo este
distanciamiento que tiene mira en eeuu o
coordinaciones bajo la mesa sea de bajo
perfil para ayudar a eeuu en esa lucha
contra los alemanes y especialmente
contra al qaeda en ese momento aquella
noche en irán a miles de personas
salieron con velas a recordar aquellas
hay personas fallecidas en nueva york'
en los otros ataques que sucedieron en
eeuu en ese momento al presidente de
este país era el presidente reformista
mohamad jatamí que había llegado con un
discurso de reconciliación de diálogo de
civilizaciones de acercamiento con
occidente y había una esperanza de que
esa distanciamiento de que ese discurso
radical contra accidente pudiera cambiar
en este país pero todo terminó con ese
gran discurso o ese famoso discurso del
presidente george w w
que el discurso a la nación en enero de
2022 del 2002 cuando declara a irán como
parte del eje del mal del que también
hacían dos coreas de parte de corea del
norte e irak desde ese momento todas las
relaciones volvieron a cambiar es el
estancia miento y ese esa desconfianza
esa esa rabia contra eeuu ese ese sentir
de la maldad de ellos contra en contra
de esta región se hizo mayor en el país
y aumentó otra vez cuando fue la
invasión en 2003 contra irak que de
hecho determinó por beneficiar era
sacaron a su gran enemigo que era el
dictador adams sadam husseim y en ese
momento irán empieza a ganar mucha
influencia en un país con el que había
sostenido una guerra de ocho años en la
década de los chinos
catalina 20 años después como sigue
haciendo eco el 11-s en oriente
pues angela para empezar nos ha dejado
cientos de miles de personas muertos y
cientos de miles de personas desplazadas
no solamente dentro de sus países sino
refugiados en otros países de la región
y en otras partes del mundo solamente en
irán hay más de 3 millones de refugiados
o inmigrantes afganos y se cree que las
cifras son mayores en turquía tenemos
otro otro tanto y en los iraquíes
también emigraron a muchísimas partes
atrás pero sí que nos ha dejado una gran
tristeza una gran destrucción no
solamente en afganistán sino también en
irak tuvo consecuencias en su momento en
ese proceso de paz entre los israelíes y
los palestinos a partir de esos dos
minutos se dieron muchísimas cosas
volvieron
anticipado pasó una guerra en gaza y de
ahí vinieron muchísimas más así que las
repercusiones y las consecuencias
especialmente en vidas humanas en
perdidas en destrucción que han habido
para la región
grandísima teniendo en cuenta que si
bien en ese momento los norteamericanos
dicen que lograron contener al qaeda en
afganistán todos hemos sido testigos de
como al qaeda resurgió y tuvo esa gran
aparición en irak luego de la invasión
norteamericana luego cuando decían que
lo habían controlado vuelven aparecen
otros grupos yihadistas como el estado
islámico que tuvo ese momento entre el
año 2014 y que 2016 cuando llegaron a
controlar más del 30 por ciento de irak
de otra gran proporción de siria así que
realmente ha sido han sido 20 años de
muchísimo dolor muchísima destrucción
para la gente de esta región y el
panorama no pareciera mejorar catalina
como se perfila ahora con el talibán en
el poder en afganistán
s es preocupante por el lado iraní y su
relación con el talibán en este momento
por ejemplo es diferente quieren un
momento de espera les quieren dar la
oportunidad han entendido de que no
pueden seguir presionando hacia una
guerra como ya sucedía hace 20 años que
estuvieron a punto pero muy cerca de una
guerra entre entre irán los talibanes
sin embargo ellos siguen insistiendo que
quieren o que aparezcan necesita un
gobierno y donde estén por delante de
todas las etnias para poder lograr la
paz nada más le interesa a irán que esta
es la estabilidad de afganistán en este
momento como les decían hay más de 3
millones de afganos en este país e irán
por las capas por la crisis económica
que atraviesa por esas sanciones tan
fuertes a las que está sometido no está
en capacidad de recibir más refugiados o
inmigrantes a carlos por eso tienen
cerradas todas estas fronteras así que
en este momento hay muchísima
preocupación por lo que pueda pasar en
este país y las resoluciones que tenga
no solamente a nivel local sino a nivel
regional con toda esta ideología los
talibanes tomando el poder en afganistán